making red rock a safer place that's the
goal of non-profit group save redrock
they're pushing to enhance the area with
a trail and new ways to protect those
who plan to visit madison kimbrough
spoke with those enjoying the outdoors
on this easter sunday about those
planned improvements she joins us live
with what people have to say madison
save red rock is currently in phase one
of creating their legacy trail that
would allow better and safer access for
those cyclists runners and walkers in
the area now through may 9 the public
can view and comment on the current
assessment of the trail's first phase
which is a 5.5 mile stretch from west
charleston boulevard and sky vista drive
in summerlin to the red rock fee station
the goal is for the red rock legacy
trail to connect summerlin with southern
highlands through the red rock canyon
area here's what some visitors had to
say about the planned improvements
almost every major city jamaica is so
car dependent and people are just now
going transitioning to like bicycling
you know skateboarding all of that stuff
i feel like it has to be addressed to
have more accessibility to people who
don't just want to see
you know gas guzzling cars as their way
of transportation
[Music]
recently the clark county commission
approved the 4.7 million dollar project
and during the virtual meeting held this
past thursday mentions of better signage
from blm and more police and security
presence along the trails were also
discussed parking upgrades and easier
accessibility to the trails were also
mentioned reporting live near red rock
madison kimbrough live local now